ええもうすでにニュースとかで見ている方がいると思いますが
12月の25日の朝よちげない
自宅にストーカーの人が侵入してきました
怖い twitter やもっとごめんなさい鬼女 twitter サボってたら9
パー looper がきますね奪うぱるパターン
埠頭カー大豆 looper
ありがとうございます一応
大丈夫でしたなんかすごいはツイッターとかで大丈夫っていうメッセージをたくさん
いただいたんでとりあえずは大丈夫ですよということをお伝えしたい所であるのとこう
いうことだといっていうことをちゃんとみなさんにお伝えしたいのもありますし
もち地溝油スト目指す東母の日がで結構多いみたいでこういうことがひょっとしたら皆
さんのミニ大きいないということもゼロではないのでウツボ科こういう手順で
警察の方に対応して頂きましたっていうのを
一応皆さんにお伝えしようと思っておりますあのとりあえず
原綺麗です全然近畿なんですけどもまぁめちゃくちゃ怖かったです
お久しぶりには動けねーなーこれってけどちょっと
固まっちゃったりしたんでまあ今は全然余裕なんですけどねなぜでしてがない人が言う
んなら入ってきたときはマジで何もできねーなーと思って後事件がた25日北後輩と
一緒に辺にいたんでなんとパっていく
たんですけど多分一人だったら固まって通報とかそういうこともできないんじゃないか
なってくらい
非常に怖い思いをしてしまいますマイケ江入られてしまってえっとぐっだけじゃないん
ですけど一回外でてもらっていいですかっていうなだめるとって言ってもらえたんで
その瞬間する鍵かけて速攻100飛ばす立っているわけです
pa ん
あっあーっ
円の中まで侵入されちゃってでもなんか無理やり今追い返したんですけど入っ
824です
じゃあ全く知らないですねでもなんかほんと自然に不法侵入されてあっ今パトにつき
ましたね
これでも即対応ですよねちょっとだけねあー構えて来てもらって速攻現行犯逮捕され
てるんですけどもあの以前動画で言っていた二棟が被害にあいましたっていう動画で
親子メールっていう僕の近くに寄った瞬間ソップた
ホっていう状況下の中で犯人の方は近づいてきたのでもう前だけそこで100登板で
逮捕してもらったんですけど
いや
怖いですよ強いてが僕が出したのはその後の話なんでそれが一逮捕するってすごい
手順をちょっと組まなきゃいけないみたいでと好きになったのが抱いたよーじっくない
でそこから警察も買ったり借り切ってトリシューラ米とか色々知ってだいたい朝の5時
半そっから北二条庁舎があったんで警察署に行って被害届を出さなきゃいけなかったん
で今色々手続きとかお話ししたり
この何か書いたりやったりして気づいたら12月25日のお昼になりました
俺のクリスマスはとこいっ僕のフューチャーズほぼ警察署ですからね
ず銀の大木チャップ誰か対抗するってそれが時間書かれたかっていうことを僕がすごい
感じました今回てくれずまた非朴朝から警察連れてかれて起きればで一睡もせずっと
取り調べしてたんですよ本当に心配してくださる方がたくさんいたんですけどもっと g
使って良かったと思っている
いますぼく人の防犯壁に持ちかけであるんで結構思ったよりスムーズに証拠とかを出た
んですけどそれでもこういう事件が起きてしまうとすっきり時間持ってかれて嫌な思い
をした職は良い思いをしたなっていう話でございます実際ですね本当に知らない人が
部屋のが入ってくるとマジで動けないですから僕後輩と二人でポケモンせたんですけど
本当に水秒ぐらい待っ
なく動けなくて恐怖でのほんと誰かと一緒に入れて本当によかったなっていう感じです
皆さんストーカー行為には気をつけましょうバイバイ
徹夜も今日行けねーよ
[音楽]
me
バッハ